d'abord je crois que c'est l'heure est
grave elle est grave parce que nous
avons un président de la République qui
se met à côté du peuple nous entrons en
ce 22 mars 2023 dans une nouvelle
période qui est un président de la
République qui devient le président en
cohabitation avec le peuple et vous
savez un président de la République il
est là avant tout et surtout pour mener
à bien des politiques au service de
l'intérêt général ce midi à 13h plus
particulièrement il a fait le choix de
se mettre à côté du peuple d'être en
cohabitation avec le peuple et donc oui
je suis inquiète je suis inquiète je
suis inquiète parce que nous avons plus
que besoin aujourd'hui de rassembler
nous avons besoin de sécuriser chacune
chacun se payer est en fracture sociale
nous le vivons là et alors encore plus
depuis jeudi dernier ce pays est en
fracture territoriale et nous l'avons
suffisamment dit ici au Sénat donc nous
avons à l'inverse de quelqu'un qui
assume nous avons besoin d'un président
de la République qui
fasse preuve d'une humilité d'une
humilité qui n'est pas une faiblesse
d'une humilité qui est qui consiste à
dire nous nous sommes trompés et nous
reprenons une feuille de route pour
satisfaire aux besoins de notre pays aux
besoins de nos concitoyens et de nos
concitoyens il n'en a rien été dans
cette interview à 13h
[Musique]